this is Jacob bernanda and Oscar
involson Educators guides and Resident
Vikings from the Viking Museum in
Stockholm Sweden today they're joining
us to break down some of the world
weaponry and mythology of 2018's God of
War oh so that's a proper Viking armor
big thanks to all at the Viking museum
for joining us on this episode make sure
to go and check them out all the links
will be in the description below but
without further Ado it's over to the
Vikings
oh
my God no you are not ready stay back
this ax looks like it's aerodynamic so
perhaps he's using it as a throwing ax
you haven't played the game Jacob I
played a little bit but I haven't used
the weapons I've just played the games
when he is in Greece the blade looks
like something mythology more like the
actual Viking blades the handle is
aerodynamic that that's why I think it's
a throwing ax
but it's quite a big blade so it looks
like a mix so what we typically call
this is a bearded ax and Jacob's ax here
well a little smaller actually looks
very similar to kratos's ax
[Music]
well he's really swinging that ax
usually
well that works you want to see it's
slightly smaller swings and usually
you'd see them fighting together the
shield as well rather than using the ax
simply one-handed
that's that's very practical with the
unfolding Shield as well yeah yeah when
we reenact fightings it would be perfect
to use something you can just pick up
when you need it because it's heavy to
run around with your heel all the time
things like a lot less space on the car
as well it does have a center bosses
well protecting the hand which is very
nice we do see there's too few shields
in historical and Fantasy games we
really need to see more of those that's
a big plus
he is throwing the ax like mjolnir it's
totally ripoff though yeah it is but I
like that
oh draggers I like them they're like
quacking zombies but better if you ask
me to me dragger is more dangerous is
more walking per person with a mind this
is more like zombies attacking from
everywhere
from the Icelandic sagas they're more
like a wise enemy who you need to
protect yourself very carefully against
oh I like the idea that the armor has
grown together with some really cells
the whole you know old being bird in the
ground and having their old rusted
equipment with them as well we don't see
a lot of armor Viking into grapes
actually so the the belief in Draeger in
in the Old Norse context that is
possibly stems from the idea the the
dead continue their lives inside their
graves and in some cases you can even go
visit them in you know the the afterlife
if you will somehow they're
simultaneously both either in Valhalla
or niflame and of course if someone was
Restless enough or wanted enough
Vengeance they could leave their Truman
we have upon the living
who are you me
I'm the greatest ambassador to the gods
the Giants and all the creatures of the
nine realms I know every corner of these
lands every language spoke and every war
waged every deal struck they call me
mamia oh so we find Nemer he's like
um a giant but he's still a best friend
of Udin so he's a special place in the
mythology but Odin's had me imprisoned
here for it
I like the the image of the horns looks
like gold and with the or Viking
ornaments on them so it looked like good
drinking horns put on the head of mimir
Kratos removes the head of mimer and
carries it along dispensing advice and
comments which is it's a fun nod to
maimer being the source of knowledge
just mimer's head is without his body is
also mentioned in this Argus because the
Giants are not very happy about this
relationship between Udin and mimer
therefore they take his head off but
Odin makes the head still survive and be
living so therefore this is a good take
from that kind of perspective too it
works yeah I'm going to cut off your
head now
good enough
[Music]
oh so that's a proper viking armor so we
are dressed wrong
um I wouldn't say that first off long
cloth pants have been a thing in
northern Europe for a very long time but
I I presume it's a not to his Greek
Origins leather armor
people love leather armor the usefulness
of it is very debatable but then again
if you're Kratos you probably don't need
all that much protection
foreign
well I'm sure that anyone living here in
the Viking age would have turned up
there wouldn't have thought of the nose
to one of these uh played Paul runs
it doesn't really fit the aesthetic it
does have some runes written on it
something like uh hear my words a gods
or a lord to sire or to conceive the
thought of siren the right the right
kingship the suit of armor does have
some redeemable qualities including
buckles not too unsimilar to this one
I'm wearing here so they have looked at
some bike new stuff at least
foreign
[Music]
actually and some of the decorations
ripped straight out of archeological
context or history the problem is that
it's Vandal period yeah I'm not working
period the plates on the belly as well
if anything it resembles
um Eastern East Asian armor from way
past the Viking age possibly and samurai
or don't quote me on that
[Music]
so the the boys outfits or ages of first
off it has a similar problem to Craters
first outfits while all of the leather
and Furs everywhere they do use leather
and fur in clothing but it's very rarely
or almost never this raw and unpolished
if you will then again they have been
living in hiding and possibly making
hunting their own clothing so I guess it
makes sense
what is this
[Music]
foreign
so the midgard snake I like that one I
like the monsters of the Norse mythology
German gander is perhaps the most famous
one is one of the sons of luki German
gander is like the world Snape he's so
long and Tall that he can wrinkle around
the whole world and bite his own tail
Thor and John magander is not best
friends they are the worst enemies of
each other and they will kill each other
in Ragnarok the Endo time yeah they are
destined to be the bane of each other at
the end of the world
foreign
absolutely Applause the fat jobber he
was probably sick of looking at it and
it's also a very fun thing that the
German Gunner is attacking the statue of
Thor so I guess they have learned about
Dermatology it's a fun take to have the
serpent talking rather than being
mindless Beast
then again being an offspring of Loki
some snark is to be expected
something's happening
well it looks like
um they are reading in runes and
watching like pictures on the stones on
the top there there's it's quite tricky
to read but there's something like
which literally translates to in the
hands of the one born by the ainer jar
that's us
presumably this refers to Kratos and
ain't Harrier R is like the the Warriors
of Valhalla if you say so
this time showing the funeral pyre of
life
in the death comes
at lost back to judging him in the hands
of ainhalia 30 anti-president will be
referring to atreus or eloki as we know
him as now and jotenheim is the place
for the Giants
thought you'd be bigger
just definitely the one
A Long Way from Home aren't you oh so we
got balder nice he's a very special God
we got sources of him but yeah of course
but I haven't seen him like this he's
more like a poor
um kind of thrall or slave look yeah he
doesn't even have a shirt he's also got
the wrong hair color but leaving
nitpicking for another time balder is
means like the light God or if you say
so and some people not us perhaps but
some people using him as a symbol of the
Viking Jesus because he's the light one
and he's also interesting because he is
dying and that's all Lucas fault and
then he comes back after Ragnarok to be
the most important god of the surviving
Gods no he's very heavily tattooed
Vikings did they use tattoos well we
don't know for sure but we have some
sources telling us that Vikings could
have on his chest he had a tattoo
written in runes Ecker Dowd I am dead on
his back he says bonding like a bound on
his neck and it says
and it could mean I'm a sign of Ragnarok
[Music]
so balder and creators are fighting and
in the sagas Boulder is described as to
very polite and beautiful the god that
everybody likes but is not that likable
so I understand Kratos why he's quite
angry at him he's also used as target
practice by the gods amusing themselves
by throwing Spears and shooting arrows
which in the original story leads to his
death by an IRA of mistletoe possibly
Kratos could have a lot more luck in
fighting him if he were to learn this
tale as well
can you make it
is it a weapon
armor or likewise an instrument of War
of which I'm a master at Chapin the
dwarfs in the old boss mythology they
they can be a bit hard to describe now
uh the names I actually recognize them
as Brock and Ettrick and the name etrick
and Cindy are used interchangeably and
they're famous of forging a couple of
things do you know which ones Jacob yeah
the most important weapons and armor of
the Gods of course and they are in a
competition with other dwarfs and they
need to make the best gifts to the gods
for example mjolnir
now the forging scene it looks very high
tech a lot more high tech than any
Viking the neighbors would have had then
again the dwarves a legendary Craftsmen
so even if they had an industrial sized
smelting oven I wouldn't mind too much
they also look a little bit like more
like Tolkien dwarfs or from The Hobbit
doctor based dwarves oh
let me guess there's a valkyrie in here
yep well are we gonna fight her there's
a trapped spirit in there quiet head
so Oscar it looks like they're fighting
Valkyries and for me that's a strange
thing because Valkyries is getting the
best warriors to Valhalla and to freyja
in Falcon this doesn't look much like
the valkyrie's I've seen there are
descriptions of the flying of the
battlefield but primarily the scene is
riding horses over the battlefield so if
I were to Give Them Wings I'd give them
winged horses rather than Wings
themselves but it's a very striking
decoration
oh I like I like the helmet that she has
at first glance it might be seen as a
horned helmet those are actually two
bird-headed terminals possibly
symbolizing the two Ravens hugin and
mooning of Odin uh their boss or
employer
so Jacob what do you think well I would
like to play the game now I heard
there's a new game coming up so I'm
looking forward to that I actually
bought the original game before I didn't
work this morning so I'm looking forward
to playing it when I get home from this
and I hope also craters could be friends
with at least one of the Gods because it
would be fun to see that too yeah
can you keep believing